so many uh great uh uh story lines in
the nfl to talk about a perfect guess
perfectly timed as we're we're going
down this pop culture wormholes the uh
the host of uh 10 questions with kyle
brown on the spotify uh podcast network
as well as good morning football 7 a.m
eastern time every single day on nfl
network one of our favorites back here
on the rich eisen show is kyle brown how
are you kyle
rich i i'm loving life are you kidding
me i i just cashed a 67 check for days
of our lives scandinavian residuals
[Music]
you saw that yesterday huh oh my god i
was laughing i love it i relate on a
very small scale and when those checks
come in yeah baby needs a new pair of
shoes let's go so do you really get
residuals from your soap work from back
in the day it's dried up you know it has
rap but for years i would get and they
would always be from some european
country i did three and a half years on
days where lives in the early 2000s
and apparently they still love them in
uh you know in finland or or holland or
wherever over there because every once
in a while get a little check and i
don't mind it
well i found out yesterday the folks in
spain love draft day man they
they can't get enough of draft day over
in spain you know um amazing that's just
so funny yeah switzerland i love that
jennifer garner in spain that's what i
heard about it i'm into it
they do dennis leary is the coach of the
cleveland browns by the way how about
that cast that casting option he told me
that he's reached out to belichick to
prepare for the role bless him is that
right i mean if you're a friend if
you're the fan of the patriots and
you're going to play a head coach in a
in an nfl film
don't you use that to try and reach out
to belichick i mean absolutely that's my
end and then i would want all the
nuances of it i like that the draft
decision hinges upon that the
quarterback had no one come to his
birthday party
i i love that movie for all its charms
and it's certainly the dennis leary bill
belichick impression is motivating hey
man so i guess which quarterback today
do you think nobody went to their
birthday party because they're not doing
well in the nfl like
that's it now that's uh that's our topic
park conversation so do you have do you
have a a movie that other people love
many people find uh they love and you
don't care for it and that's the hot
take do you got one of those can i tell
you rich
i'm not a big christmas story guy hey
i'm calling you and me i'm not a
christmas story guy either i'm not i'm
kind of seeing it now from a different
perspective than i did as a child like
and now is it a parent so let me get
this straight
ralphie wants a a projectile weapon for
christmas now
his parents tell him the whole show the
whole movie you're gonna shoot your eye
you're gonna shoot your eye out in 12
seconds of them having the dumb gun that
they bought them because they're saps he
shoots his damn eye out they were right
and then on top of that like the episode
in the alley with scott farkas i think
that ralphie has some rage issues i
don't know if i want him having a
projectile weapon the whole thing
strikes me terrible now as a parent and
i'm out okay so now it just doesn't that
so you and i are locked up on that yeah
yeah it's kind of a miserable movie like
it's
he he blames his uh using the the f-bomb
on flick next door and then flick gets i
think beaten by his mom over the phone
and then ralphie has soap in his mouth
and that there's a miserable santa claus
who kicks him in the face down the slide
it's like it's actually kind of this
weird horror take on christmas and i
don't want my kids to see that yeah i
get you i trust me but you know kids
movies are different when you grow up
and you get you know and then you have
fresh perspective perfect example i'm
showing my kids beauty and the beast
years ago and i'm like do am i teaching
my sons that
one day if they find somebody who they
like a lot all you got to do is just
lock that person up in the library
downstairs and they'll they'll come
around like is that is that is that the
message i'm sending them you know and
everything it is you know in every
disney movie the parents eat it in in
every single disney movie i'm like what
am i telling my kids right now you know
yeah belle's mom is nowhere to be seen
and then you know rich the disney
formula was just kill off all the
parents and they're like no we're going
to start differently we're going to have
this frozen movie and this these two
young gals they're great it's a
beautiful family and look they live in
this castle and everything 10 minutes
into the movie both parents killed in
about dead
yes they go down with a ship
yeah it's awful awful it is
all right very good carl brand here on
the rich eisens show um
so i will ask you the question that
chris brockman asked me earlier on in
our
news segment that uh we just came up
with because we had it we had time to
kill um called uh what what are we
calling it what's more like what's more
likely oh i love it okay
so uh ask him the question about this
weekend's uh big week 11 match up in
arrowhead chris brockman ask him
that one massive game there uh kyle
cowboys chiefs yep
what's more likely
cowboys make the super bowl
chiefs put make the super bowl go for it
kyle bryant floors well i'm looking at
this game i i'm calling it the poser
bowl one of these teams is posers
they're trying to be cool and they're
not we're gonna find out one it's it's
one of these like
wwe does like their loser leaves town
like i i'm not interested in either of
these teams whoever they lose if they
win
i think dallas is more likely guys i
really do i i i'm actually picking
dallas outright in this game because
we shifted we for two months we said
what's wrong with the chiefs and then
this week we said are the chiefs back i
don't think so i rich i look at it this
way when i was in my um let's call it my
drinking prime in my mid-20s i would
often suffer a hangover and the next day
uh in the morning like the day is wasted
you want to get off the couch you feel
like hell terrible decisions that was
the cheese for a while and then
inevitably there was this moment around
2 p.m when it just would feel like it
was gone i think it's fine i think i can
get up and be productive that's nonsense
it's just a brief respite from your
hangover it's hangover fool's gold you
go out you try to do something and hit
you like a ton of bricks a half hour
later i think we got the hangover fool's
gold last week from the chiefs against
the raiders
i really do i'm not going to take the
cheese on that one i still don't think
this is a great team i think dallas is
going to beat them i chose the chiefs
because the afc is an easier path to the
basket here in los angeles than the nfc
you know that at some point the cowboys
are gonna have to go up against one of
the bays
uh potentially potentially somebody from
the nfc west
who i imagine will have a better chance
of it in january than the current state
of the top of the nfc west right now
with the banged up cardinals and then
the rams whatever's going on with them
and that's why that's why i chose the
chiefs that's right it's a good point
because the word we've been using uh the
afc right now is goulash it's just a
bunch of mishmash and spices and meat
and sauce and i don't think anything
really sticks that's an absolute mess if
you were to say rich one of these fun
conversations we would go back to august
and be like all right heading into
thanksgiving the number one team in the
afc is going to be the titans without
derrick henry correct that's asinine
it's ridiculous or we have them right we
have the bills who uh lost nine to six
to the jaguars we have the titans who
lost to the jets we have the ravens who
got crushed by the dolphins there is no
there is no champion if you're gonna do
a trial by combat in the afc i really
don't even know who you're throwing in
with if the strongest choice is the
titans without their 2000 yard rusher
that's a wild conference well uh here's
here's here's my mountain for that uh
trial by combat
patriots
here's oh here we go let's go
yeah that's what i'm saying it starts
tonight you know short week game on the
road and i know you could say atlanta
list atlanta that and who they really
beating in their their win streak but
you still got to beat who's in front of
you in a short week game on the road is
no joke in the nfl then you're then
you're home for the titans and then
you're at the bills these next three
weeks will show whether the rubber is
truly meeting the road
um we've seen this movie before kyle
this movie has been shown before and i
know uh what uh
mj10 is not tb12
but um if this is 2001 we had matt light
on earlier it kind of does look like the
same movies on on spooling what do you
think it's really fun it it does feel
like a movie i think the best barometer
of right now where the patriots are are
if you get into the heart of the bill's
mafia and because they're right there
and watching it i get the privilege i
get to talk pretty often to steve tasker
and
i was talking to he and chris brown a
few days ago that he works with and you
know they're going off they're so
sensitive in defense of the bills about
what's going on with the patriots and
they're saying oh come on everybody's
hyping this mac jones and they think the
patriots can do this come on that's
crazy and i go well guys you are a
little nervous right like oh we're
terrified we're absolutely happy
yeah man they're terrified because this
is the best part
let's say let's say the patriots do get
in the playoffs and let's say they win a
playoff game and they lose in the
divisional round that's nothing that's a
drop in the bucket if you are the bills
if you are the afc
2021 is
nothing i'm thinking about the 2029
patriots the 2034 patriots head coach by
josh mcdaniels still with mac jones
they're attempting to do the
back-to-back great quarterbacks that's
this year with small potatoes it's the
fact that maybe they have found someone
and guess what that guy can't run fast
he can't do the no-look pass he's not
kylo murray he just stands there and
plays quarterback just like the guy
before him that's the real night exactly
and it doesn't look like he's bothered
by anything no nothing like he's not
breaking his sweat even though obviously
what he's doing is highly highly
difficult and you know when when toe
meets ball on that monday night
right and week what i guess that's 13
so in week baker's dozen to wrap up
monday night and it's bills versus
patriots and it's time you know there
will be a lot of butterflies in the in
the bill's mafia stomach because what if
like last year
you could say the bills finally flipped
the script and i thought that was going
to be the narrative coming in because
which team doesn't have a stumble with a
rookie quarterback well the 2021
patriots are sure showing that
is not always the case so when it all
comes down to it last year you could
throw it out like that was brady out and
cam in and you know and who the heck
knew what was going on with that
quarterback situation this is kind of a
different story like now is the time to
slay that dragon now
right i gave belichick a year whatever
he had opt-outs he was trying a thing
with cam it wasn't there hand-picked the
quarterback hand-picked the free agents
this has handprints all over it and i
remember when the bill smoked the
patriots the end of last year there was
this long embrace and exchange between
belichick and mcdermott and it really
looked like belichick is saying you know
it's passing the torch love you classy
guy take it away
and and not a chance i've even gone past
this rich have you have you even in your
excitement about the patriots and i know
you have it and you should have you
allowed yourself if you indulged in the
idea
that it could be a tampa versus new
england supreme court of course you even
thought about it of course it has
crossed my mind but i just crossed my
mind but it is still just so
you know
difficult to even
comprehend what that would look like in
los angeles
that would be off the charts now because
that was that's what we were all talking
about the minute that brady left to go
to tampa is like well they don't play
new england until 2021 so how about the
super bowl this year especially since
it's in tampa
and um we all know certainly right
around this time last year as brady was
who knew getting ready to be boat raced
by the kansas city chiefs in the first
quarter of that game of thanksgiving
weekend that was the sunday thanksgiving
and roma was like i don't know jim maybe
they'll be playing each other on this
field and he was right you know and so
um
you can't discount it right now man i
know i can't and i think that the
his most impressive game
was a game that he lost his most
impressive game was against against
brady right
he wasn't great he didn't put up huge
numbers he didn't win but he just he
didn't his poston bounce and he
outplayed brady that's all these young
guys all i care about is
do they freak out do they lose their
head he didn't that's the one i remember
it's not even any of this win streak
it's that one and oh god i'd sell my
soul to have that replay at all
kyle not only have i thought about it
but on monday
you could have bet a patriots bucks
super bowl at 33 to one 33 maybe i did
okay all right
are you i guess you know as you know uh
as an nfl employee i do not uh condone
this behavior as a matter of fact i
frown upon it and i'm actually confused
by it i don't know what you mean by
the future or something like that what's
33 to one that that's gonna be the final
score you can't score one
nicely done don't worry about it guys
drinks on me that way nicely done don't
worry he's just prepared in his own
house with uh sarah tiano rooting for
the falcons tonight it's like is this a
separate is this a separate television
situation oh no she knows what's gonna
happen oh god
all right uh so you had bill pullman on
your pod um
yes and you went flat out right in on
the speechifying for for independence
day and um you know we had him here in
studio last week and we we were
preparing i'll tell you what we wanted
to do was to give him a little megaphone
and have him read out the uh playoff
speech and the uh we are who the bears
we thought they were speech and then and
then the the tomlin never say never but
never speech
um but then we heard that he hates
people coming up with ideas exactly like
that
and i'm like oh no but you got him to
actually go there you actually got him
he he was saying some of the speech
himself right i had him finish the
speech about the final line and then
what we did which i guess either he was
willing to do was i said all right bill
let's bring in some some some
competitors to this coliseum right here
i think it's the greatest hype speech in
movie history but coming through door
number one let's play william wallace
let's play her brooks let's play jordan
bell for wolf of wall street and we
played them all
and he maintained he stood up for
himself he said i still think that
president whitmore is better and he had
great takes he said listen the herb
brooks miracle speech is fantastic the
william wall speech is fantastic
i wasn't just talking to the united
states or to scotland i'm talking to the
entire world united against this foreign
enemy and i got goosebumps when he said
it i think he's right mankind man you
know at some point you can't you can't
trump uh when you're trying to save
mankind you know
you can't but he's a he's a complete
gentleman uh sweetheart right there's
one point where i wanted to shake him by
the shoulders though he gets he gets
spaceballs okay he's really young he has
very few credits mel brooks sees him in
a play and says i want that guy to be
lone star in my star wars spoof
during the the shooting and the entire
process of making that movie pullman
reveals that he had never seen star wars
never saw the movie had no idea and i
said bill
so you're doing a lightsaber fight with
moranis and you're you know john candy
is dressed as some sort of dog and you
didn't even get the references
and he's like well you know i'm just
sticking what's on the page i was
incredulous about it and yet he pulled
it off
wow next thing you're going to tell me
next thing you could tell me cleavon
little never saw a western before
blazing
my god
i gotta think that you know the wayans
brothers when they were making the scary
movie had seen scream they probably saw
it before but not pullman he just does
what's on the page
kyle always appreciate our chats uh
appreciate it uh we'll see you on good
morning football again tomorrow every
day at 7 00 a.m eastern time and uh
who's on your next pod you got one you
want to promote or where you're still
yeah i got a um we got a bunch of them
coming up uh
jk simmons the inimitable jk simmons um
oscar winner whiplash and um
i think we're going to get sebastian
maniscalco who have always wanted to
talk to him
that's the best that's so funny nice now
there's a lot of chipotle there's a
couple of ohio state connections with
those two right there number one is jk
simmons whenever he comes on this show
it's a difficult interview for me
because he is a die hard but oh my god i
think his dad was a music teacher
um and so that's what makes the whiplash
um you know
uh i guess gig so much important and
maniscalco visited
um ohio state prior to the oregon game
this this year uh and he wore blue at
practice and i uh you know so i i think
he's the reason why ohio state has a
loss this year that's true oh yeah
yeah so if you haven't interviewed him
bring that one up he'll no i never have
but i think he just did half the prep
there you go there you go there you go
my pleasure thanks again kyle you're
you're you're terrific and i always
appreciate you calling let's just be the
best rich and no more christmas story
fellas i'm out on i'm sorry it's a mic
drop everybody that's kyle brian
everyone
oh now there he is it's the bunny rabbit
now he's in the bunny rabbit outfit hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here